nous sommes sur place dans cette
ville très pittoresque de Gordo qui est les
contreforts des Alpes et elle double
pour la ville de Deane dans le roman Dean
est décrit comme une sorte
de village au sommet d'une montagne et c'est haut sur
la montagne un peu plus près de  Dieu mais
hier, dans la quête de Tom pour obtenir des
vues incroyables qui établiront et vendront vraiment
l'abaque du voyage de Virgile, nous avons
littéralement escaladé une montagne, tout le monde
devait porter tout son équipement à la main
jusqu'au sommet de la montagne, certaines personnes
avaient 45 minutes  monter une pente très raide
sommet très rocheux de la montagne
froid glacial juste à la toute fin de l'
hiver je pensais que tout le monde était un vrai
soldat en fait cela m'a vraiment aidé à
opérer les premiers jours en
France parce que j'avais besoin de comprendre comment
je  Je voulais que la caméra fonctionne musicalement
et je me suis retrouvé le premier jour sur
le premier plan au sommet d'une montagne
avec Hugh Jackman et le soleil se
couchait et vous savez je n'avais pas
forcément décidé à l'avance  e mais j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait quelque chose à propos de l'ordinateur de poche
qui me permettait de bouger dedans dans une danse
avec la musique
libre le dernier à quel point c'est étrange parce
qu'au début du film je me
tiens au sommet de la
montagne sans vêtements et  il fait environ
moins trois degrés et il y a de la vapeur
qui sort de ma bouche c'est réel